-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
That's so good to hear.
Let's get to the news.
President Biden said today
he will withdraw all U.S. troops
from Afghanistan
by September 11th
during a speech in
the White House Treaty Room,
which is where former
President George W. Bush
announced the start of the war
In fact, all the decorations
were still up.
President Biden spoke to
Russian President Vladimir Putin
yesterday on the phone.
Probably the scariest person
who could have called Bide
besides this guy.
"Jill, I took out a revers
mortgage on the White House.
No, it's not scam.
Magnum totally promised me."
Former President Trump's
CDC Director Robert Redfield
has reportedly joined a compan
named Big Ass Fans,
which claims that
their home air systems
can reduce
coronavirus infection.
For more information
on their products,
do not Google it at work.
Bernie Madoff, the mastermin
behind the largest Ponzi schem
in U.S. history died today
and for once, it's no big loss
A woman was recently arreste
in New York's JFK
International Airport
for carrying three pounds
of cocaine in her bra,
and she might have
gotten away with it
if she hadn't put it all
in one cup.
That's right.
A woman was recently arreste
at New York's JFK
International Airport
for carrying three pounds
of cocaine in her bra.
Even worse, it was discovere
during a routine motor boating
Allie Hord wrote that joke
Feel free
to throw her picture up.
Oh, there she is.
[ Laughing ] That was take
right after she wrote it.
Officials in Ohio
recently passed a bill
that allows residents
to have alcohol
delivered to their doorsteps
seven days a week,
which is big for
"da beer" industry
and even bigger for DeWine
It's the governor of Ohio.
The writer of that joke,
Ian Morgan,
thought you'd all know
Governor Jeff DeWine.
It's actually Mike DeWine.
Did you [bleep] know that?
Also, because "DeWine"
was coming,
I had to say "da beer" industry.
So many things deeply wron
with that joke.
I'm sure that's the last
we've heard of Ian today.
Taco Bell opened its first
digital-only location
in the U.S. today,
which will require customers
to order ahead online
or use in-store kiosks.
Order ahead? Taco Bell isn't
something you plan for.
It's like "Us" magazine
at the check-out counter.
It's an impulse buy.
Lawmakers in Colorado
are considering a new measur
that would allow people
to turn their bodies
into soil after death.
It's an important conversation
to have with your loved ones
even if it makes you sod.
Ian again.
Like Jason in
a "Friday the 13th" movie.
And he's got to be dead
after "DeWine" joke.
Aah!
And finally,
according to a recent poll
52% of Americans
are not at all interested
in having an open relationship
Said the pollster, "All right.
It doesn't hurt to ask."
And that was the monologue
everybody.